I've got plenty to be thankful for
I need so small I buy them all at the
five and ten cent store oh my God
[Music]
I used to love this town
until what happened that night
tired of pretending like everything is
normal and it's not I want things to go
back to normal too
show some enthusiasm Thanksgiving is an
institution here
[Applause]
someone's up for revenge and they're
turning it into a sick holiday game
this is weird
we're all tagged and our names are at
the table but why us
foreign
[Music]
straight off a Thanksgiving table I
don't want to spend my life looking over
my shoulder we need to stop him
[Applause]
it is going to be a very Happy
Thanksgiving
let's see